if men if masculinity has toxic traits  then how can feminine not you know i i  hear toxic femininity but it's by  feminists by girls that are like calling  girls more traditional toxic  which is it's the crazy thing the phrase  doesn't hold the same weight when it  goes the other way no no it's like they  just use the toxic  to  when it benefits them basically do you  think it's too late for women to be  treated traditional some i i think after  the development of birth i don't i don't  think it was feminism necessarily i  think it was more the development of  birth control and the lack of  consequences for women okay so when  before women valued a guy that was  a provider more